مرحبا بكم من جديد مره حاله جديده يستعد
لها نجم المنتخب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو عاقبه تعاقد رسمي مع نادي النصر
السعودي في صفقه ربما تكون الاضخم على
مستوى العالم وفق مراقبين فصفقه ستكون
فوائدها عظيمه جدا على كافه المستويات
الفنيه والجماهيريه والاستثماريه سواء
لنادي النصر او حتى للرياضه السعوديه كما
تعتبر في نفس الوقت خارطه طريق جديده
للرياضه السعوديه ونادي النصر الذي سيصبح
حاضرا في كل وسائل الاعلام العالميه حيث
ارتفعت القيمه السوقيه لنادي النصر
السعودي بالنسبه اربعه 34% بعد تعاقده مع
الاسطوره البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
بعقد يمتد الى 2025 حسب موقع قصر ماركت
الشهير والمختص في قيمته واسعار اللاعبين
الامريكي وجاء هذا بعد ان سجل نادي النصر
السعودي لكره القدم على حسابه في انستغرام
ارتفاع عدد المتابعين من 860 الف الى نحو
4 ملايين متابع في غضون ساعات حيث يتضاعف
عدد متابعي النصر الى اربع مرات على
انستغرام تكلفه انتقال رونالدو بلغت اكثر
من 200 مليون يورو في العام بحيث تعتبر
هذه القيمه اكبر راتبا على الاطلاق في
تاريخ الرياضه
[موسيقى]
ناقش الموضوع من الرياض مع عادل البطيء
اللاعب السابق ومن الرياض كذلك مستشار
الاستثمار في التسويق الرياضي خالد ربيعان
مرحبا
بكمين وكل عام وانتم بخير كابتن عادل
مع اعلان الخبر رسميا يعني هناك ناس يعني
قسموا المبلغ على الشهور وعلى الايام وعلى
الدقائق وحتى الثواني وكل من استمع الخبر
قال ما ما اكثر حظك يا كريستيانو رونالدو
يا ريتني طلعت لاعب كره قدم ولكن السؤال
هنا هل يستحق كريستيانو رونالدو هذا
المبلغ 200 مليون يورو في السنه
اولا نحييك استاذ صهيب وحيي زميلي واخوي
الاستاذ خالد الربيعان وقبل ما ابدا في
الرياضه بقول
استمتعت في الحديث السياسي اللي دار معكم
مع انني لا اجيده ههه ولكني عرفت ان حوارت
انه واختلافاتنا في الرياضه اسهل بكثير
بصراحه الاختلافات
اعانكم الله
بالتاكيد
انت تكلمت المحاور اللي تكلمت عنها في
البدايه شيء عظيم جدا ناحيه فنيه ناحيه
استثماريه مردود سمعه كل هذه الامور نقاط
يمكن نتكلم عنها بشكل اوسع لكنها بدون شكل
تاثيرها انت تكلمت عن اللي يتكلمون عن
المبلغ الدليل اللي في الصلاه حتى
بالدقائق والثواني هذا يعني انه ردت فعل
غير عاديه همم من ناحيه فنيه مؤكد هو
اسطوره يعني نتكلم لو تكلمنا عن لاعب في
العقدين كلنا حديث رونالدو ميسي يطول عن
هذا الحسابات واللي في وسائل التواصل
تتجاوز المليار بل تصل للمليرين كل هذا
يؤكد ان احنا امام حدث غير عادي انت لو
شفتوا الشارع الرياضي انتهى الحديث الا عن
كريستيانو بمختلف المول هلال نصر اهل
اتحاد كافه الانديه بل لان الشارع
بموضوعيه رياضيا يعني غير متوقع ااا منه
الكثير يعني اقول بصراحه يعني بالنظر الى
عمره همم ولكن تسويقيا بالنسبه للرياضه
السعوديه واللي نادي النصر
للسعوديه بشكل عام يعني ال- ال- العائد من
من استقدام كريستيانو رونالدو اكثر من همم
العائد الرياضي دعنا نقول ام لا همم يمكن
تحقيق الامرين
الجزء الثاني مؤكد انه ناجح مئه في المئه
من ناحيه تسويق وسمعه ورعايات بل اننا
نحتاج في المؤتمرات الصحفيه ان يكون معنا
اكثر من مترجم لانه اكيد بيحضر اسبانيا
وانجليزي يعني انا اقصد ان الحدث غير عادي
من الناحيه الثانيه النقطه الاولى اللي
تكلمت عنه الناحيه الفنيه الصحيح هو اداء
في كاس العالم ما كان بالمستوى لكن لا
يمكن ان نختزل
مستوى رونالدو في السنه الاخيره قد يعتبر
يعني انت تعرف ان اللاعب خارج الملعب هو
رجل من ضابط بشكل كبير احنا نتابع كل شيء
عنه حتى وهو في ريال مدريد او مانشستر
عنده تدريب في بيته بل احنا دخلنا فيه
تفاصيل سكنها الخاص وكيف يتمرن وكيف في
الاستشفاء كل الامور
يعني
المستشار خالد
استاذ خالد لو سمحت النقطه الاخيره بس
استاذ خالد يعرفها اكثر مني
كيف نستثمره من ناحيه توقيت مباريات
من ناحيه النقل التلفزيوني كيف يوصل كل
العالم يبحث عن 20 كل الاستاذ خالد يفهم
اكثر مني في الجوانب هذا طيب استاذ خالد
ربيعان كيف سي ينعكس ما يعني ما هي
الفائده من استخدام كريستيانو رونالدو
اللي يلعب في نادي النصر السعودي بهذا
المبلغ صفقه ربما الاضخم في تاريخ الرياضه
يورو في السماء
عادل البطيء
واشكره على الاطراء الجميل
وايضا اشكرك استاذ صهيب
التاثير رونالدو هيكون تاثير همم قوي جدا
على الساحه الرياضيه السعوديه همم نحن
يعني هو كان لبنى الاساسيه اللي هتكون
اللي منطلق جديد اللي هو منطلق صناعه
الرياضه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اللي
بدا يمكن قبل سنتين او ثلاث سنوات من خلال
الدعم الكبير اللي همم
الحكومه همم خادم الحرمين ولي العهد حسب
همم
بنود الرؤيا برؤيه 20 30 همم طبعا هي
تعتبر من الصفقات الضخمه جدا اللي همم
راتب همم يتقضا اللاعب في العالم الان
يعتبر رونالدو وانعكاساتها على الرياضه
السعوديه كثيره جدا خاصه الرياضه السعوديه
انعكاس همم همم في السوشيال ميديا كشفناها
الفتره الاخيره انعكاسات ضخمه جدا يعني في
السوشيال ميديا اخلي بضرب لك مثل همم شهد
الاعلان اكثر حوالي 70 مليون همم متابع
همم في في همم الانستغرام ايضا همم
شهد الاعلام اسف بتويتر باعلان نادي النصر
بتويتر 70 مليون همم متابعه مليون مشاهده
ايضا الانستغرام في نادي النصر همم 25
مليون مشاهده همم ايضا من عند رونالدو
الحساب الخاص في نادي في رونالدو ايضا 30
مليون مشاهده هذه لها تاثيرات كبيره جدا
اذا ما علمنا ان 80% من سكان العالم
يعرفوا انه رونالدو انتقل لنادي النصر او
همم
وجاء المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتداول
وتداول اسمين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
نادي النصر تداول كبير جدا 9 همم اللي هو
67% عندي اعلان رونالدو ولا اي منتج لاي
منتج سواء منتج خدمي هيكون من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في المرحله القادمه
67% من المشاهدين هذا الاعلان يتاثرون
بهذا الاعلان ويجعلون ال- ال- الاستاذ
خالد ربيعان كيف يعني يعني صحيح ال ال هذا
هذا عباره عن عن استثمار همم كبير جدا همم
200 مليون يورو في السنه لهذا اللاعب طبعا
هي صفقه مهمه جدا وكما تفضلت يعني هي فيها
همم
تسويق كبير جدا كيف سينعكس ذلك يعني كل
هذه همم هذا الاستثمار همم هذه الصفقه كيف
ستكون انعكاساتها على مسار التنميه على
ليس فقط على مجال الرياضه في السعوديه بل
كذلك على مجال التنميه والتطوير الحاصل
همم التحديث الحاصل الان في السعوديه كيف
سيكون انعكاسه على هذا المشهد داخل
المملكه
طبعا اذا علمنا احنا ان رونالدو هو عاقده
مع النادي النصر مده سنتين ونصف وعقدا مع
ال ال ال ال السعوديه
حوالي اربع سنوات ونصيب المجموعه سبع
سنوات العقد كامل مجموعه سبع سنوات هذه
الليله بيستخدم فيها بعدين تاثيرات سياحيه
كبيره على المملكه العربيه السعوديه تاثير
ثقافي تاثير ترفيهي تاثير ايضا اقتصادي
بالاضافه الى تاثير الرياضي كامل واللي
هيكون ان شاء الله هو اللي بين الاساسيين
اللي تطوير صناعه الرياضه همم اذا علمنا
ايضا ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والقطاعات الخاصه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه تطور التطور مذهل وقطاع الرياضه
الان يمشي بالمسار نفسه بالتوازي معهم
للانطلاق ان شاء الله لعالم جديد في عالم
رياض السعوديه وعالم جديد من الاستثمار
الاستثمارات الرياضيه السعوديه اللي حتى
تنعكس ان شاء الله اجابه على الناتج
المحلي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه باذن
الله همم ايضا التاثير اذا اضرب لك مثلا
لا يظل ان النادي على نادي النصر هيكون
تاثير رياضي تاثير حضور تاثير حضوري حضور
المدرجات منتجات عضويات اعلانات سواء
رعايات ايضا في شجانب مهم وهي لغه العصر
الحاليه الان الموجوده وهي لغه السوشيال
ميديا السوشل ميديا ذات التاثير الاكبر
والاعظم في عالم كره القدم او عالم
الاعمال في العالم هو التاثير الاكبر وهي
المغذي الاساسي في الانطلاق ان شاء الله
نعم هي انعكاسات فعلا يعني هي استراتيجيه
تبدو لافته عندما همم يعني يتم استخدام
همم اسطوره مثل كريستيانو رونالدو يلعب في
نادي النصر السعودي وكما تفضل همم الاستاذ
الربيعان انه له همم انعكاسات ابعد من
الرياضه الى الجانب الاقتصادي السياحي
التنموي همم والتسويقي كذلك همم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه همم كابتن
البطيء بالنسبه للرياضه بالنسبه فقط
للنادي النصر كذلك للرياضه السعوديه كره
القدم السعوديه وبالنسبه للمنافسه
الرياضيه بين بقيه ال- الانديه في
الدوريات السعوديه ما تاثير هذه الصفقه
تاثير ايجابي وتحفيز ومن خلال التقرير
استاذ صهيب لو شوف جبته اسم مودريتش
وراموس وبوسكيت واسماء كبيره بل ان الامر
يزيد اصبح وجود كريستيانو وسيله جذب حتى
للاعبين الاصغر سنا يعني الاسماء اللي تم
التطرق لها ميسي يعني كلهم 35 36 37 لكن
اذا حضر زي ميسي ورونالدو ومودريتش من
اسماء هذه بتكون وسيله جذب حتى للاعبين
يعني الاصغر سنا يعني بالنسبه لنا كان حلم
انه نشوف احد اللاعبين المهمين او يعني هم
اساطير اثنين في العقدين الاخيره
كريستيانو وميسي انه نشوف واحد منهم
يتواجد في الكره السعوديه وانا اتذكر صهيب
قبل سنوات حضر في مناسبه مانشستر يونايت
حضر هنا في السعوديه في الرياض كان الحديث
كله عن كريستيانو وكيف يلعبوا مع انه كان
في البدايات اليوم حنا كانه نصحى من حلم
يعني كنا نقول لو يجي في مناسبه معينه
للمملكه يكون في حديث غير عادي اليوم همم
اصول كريستيانو باثر حتى على المشهد
الرياضي بشكل عام وحتى على المشهد الخارجي
من ناحيه حضور اللاعيبه يعني ولكن هل
تعتقد انك كريستيانو سيعطي افضل ما عنده
بالنظر يعني طبعا بعد ادائه في كاس العالم
الاخيره
لا بالتاكيد بالتاكيد لن يعطي افضل ما
يعني ما راح اقول لك انه نفس الاداء في
ريال مدريد ولا في مانشستر لكن بالتاكيد
انه برده احنا لازم نعرف انه كل دوري لهم
ناس تتكلم عن الدوري الانجليزي الدوري
الاسباني الفئه الاولى واللي لهم في
الدوري السعودي لا يمكن ان يكون اعلى فئه
اذا كريستيانو اذا اذا اعطى خلينا نقول 60
50% 70% من اداء كريستيانو المعروف بيكون
مؤثر تمرين بجانب بس همم
في بانوراما لهذا المساعد اللاعب السابق
من الرياض والمستشار خالد الربيعان شكرا
جزيلا لكم همم مشاهدينا شكرا لكم على
المشاهدين
[موسيقى]